ils ont écouté c'est ainsi qu'on
pourrait nommer l'épisode 4 de koh lanta
les armes secrètes diffusé ce week-end
sur tf1 c'était vingt candidats sur la
ligne de départ voilà une nouvelle
aventure hier a dû faire ses adieux
vendredi soir candice ou plutôt
candidats trop naïve et qui a été
victime de la plus haute trahison de la
part de son équipe rouge
est-ce que vous avez un sentiment de
trahison si du côté des jaunes après
toujours d'aventuré alléluia ils ont
réussi à faire du feu on a le feu on
dise elle s'est vue et un de son
flambeau devant 5 26 millions
téléspectateurs stupéfait alors
koh-lanta les candidats ont-ils été trop
violent avec andy faut alors on va on va
en parler dans maintenant juste mercedes
sur la question sur tandis non je ne
pense pas qu'ils ont été trop dur on
sait depuis maintenant trente saisons
que koh lanta stratégie où il faut être
un peu dur on s'est parlé le mercedes on
sait penser qu'elle est trop gentil
voile elle s'est un peu victimiser mais
c'est normal ou non au bout de trente
saisons c'est que dans koh lanta il faut
être dur il n'a pas été assez duré a
laissé percer là c'est jeanine sur les
costumes et gilles verdez me candice
elle est nulle contrainte de venir au
monde
elle trouve un collier elle partage sa
trouvaille qu'il faut jamais fermer
première erreur stratégique
deuxième erreur elle ne le sors pas au
conseil alors que tout le monde sait
même elle arrive est éliminé quand on
fait deux erreurs stratégiques comme ça
vous méritez de sortir de koh lanta on
est pas à koh lanta pour faire du feu
vert c'était trop bien je me suis
délectée avec un plaisir coupable
pourtant il ya une trahison qui est
horrible pour elle il faut dire que l'un
remax in qu'ils ont éliminés aujourd'hui
elles ont dû couper leurs commentaires
sur instagram tellement elles se font
démonter sur les réseaux sociaux
et ben moi j'ai adoré ça alors suis
désolé mais ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu un épisode très sérieux
un hulk pour candice 1 dans cet épisode
la jeune femme a trouvé donc un collier
d'immunité et sans avoir réussi à se
mettre tout le monde dans la poche
semble celle qui ne perd pas de temps
c'est candice est là discrètement révélé
qu'elle a trouvé un collier d'immunité
en collier comme défensif c'est bien
beau mais avoir des alliés amis c'est
c'est bien mieux qu'un objet quand même
du jeep entendu tombe ce serait vraiment
du gaspillage passé le monde qu'il faut
appeler été victime en surpoids dans mes
bras mon sens on vraiment ouvert les
yeux effectivement sur la situation
comme quoi j'étais vraiment pas si en
danger que ça j'ai envie de faire les
thèmes que ça fait vraiment du bien
d'être de santé à priser de cda non en
fait on n'est pas tout seul finalement
on compte des si on n'avait pas le monde
contre temps à pendant tout ce temps
comment oui qu'est-ce qui se passe non
parce que j'entends ce que vous lui
dites donc vois ça me fait rire mais je
veux pas les recours pour répéter non
j'ai dit que j'étais un [ __ ] oui parce
que je trouve que ça a bien tenu
honnêtement cinq sur six bisons suis pas
qu'un sursis blaoui connu pour ses parts
du marché parce qu'ils ont pris une
grosse claque perdu un million c'est
quand même énorme pour que l'on taille
pour tf1 mais si on revient à jouer ce
soir mais je vous dirais bien aimé l'un
ou capa sur koh lanta c'est bien sûr je
les autres tout à l'heure
maison que tpm paix comme ça donc on dit
la vérité
moi j'ai gt 5 millions si c'est très
bien merci sega la wii mais une vanessa
matz non ça m'a fait chier que ce soit
battu par capillarité alors par les
audiences aux deux camps d'islam et tout
ce que tu veux
moi j'avais envie de revenir sans qu'en
dise parce que vous êtes tous méchants
méchants avec elle c'est chaud non mais
je trouvais excusez moi mais moi je les
trouvais quand même superbe
moi je sais que si je faisais partie de
koh lanta j'aurais aimé être copine avec
elle parce qu'elle ramenait de la bouffe
et sa soirée vous marier non mais c'est
super important parce que on est en
baisse c'est vrai aussi
non mais franchement c'est bien là elle
faisait beaucoup pour le camp et ça a
été violent comment ils ont ils ont
chassé quand même mais non mais
maintenant c'est que c'est david lanta
que c'est un jeu ils ont été violents
delà des autres événements marquants de
cet épisode c'est lorsque l'équipe des
jaunes est parvenu enfin récupérer le
feu sur leur camp après des jours sans
ça c'est un gros truc quoi alors
c'est fou le feu bah ils ont pas mal
mais ils ont galéré
[Rires]
[Musique]
très honnêtement je n'ai que très
moyennement confiance en la capacité de
vingt cinq mille feux ces vestiges
à le faire
[Musique]
ouais
on a le feu
[Musique]
c'est bon à boire du oui alors le ce
pardon nathalie mais qu'en dise on l'a
beaucoup mais c'est pas sos amitié elle
était catastrophique
elle est soit disant ex berton sur la
même page les six affaires du fait même
et moi ce que j'aime dans koh lanta
notre côté univers impitoyable avec la
stratégie sans foi ni loi
c'est bien il faut être très méchant il
faut assumer d'être méchant à bruno de
la région écologiquement pour l
certainement extrêmement malade mais pas
tout le temps va jouer la saison
chaudron très réussi la saison est
vraiment très très réussie mais je
reviens à la bataille parce que castaldi
une fois de plus dit il y avait souvent
des erreurs c'est évidemment c'est un
drame pour tf1 mais lui c'est pas une
question bien sûr que si c'est une des
remarques de tf1 et ça veut dire mais
juste ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que la plus grosse marque
de francs bien sûr eh ben tu peux plus
forte que la plus grosse marque de tf1
il ya bien sûr c'est donc ces pressions
en termes de communication ses deux
ceintures c'est une catastrophe totale
géant mémorisées pour mémoire écolo
saissac et où j'attendais le fasse à
paris c'est à dire que marleau et plus
forme de kolontar series on avait dix
ans un artisan et surtout parlé ici et
tout le monde n'était pas d'accord et
que cette stratégie nation de deux
mètres le capitaine marc l'eau là-bas si
oui c'est fort que le mardi mais enfin
il avait rien le vendredi ou samedi sur
france 2 donc là ils sont en train de
tout doucement d'avancé non mais je suis
désolé même si le fait qu'ils soient et
soit terminé parce que si c'est une
catastrophe
au revoir les séries de regarder entre
fronts connaissez mais a tardé
même si sûr si bien évidemment
heureusement que tu es fin de bon mais
c'est juste le succès 1 millions de
téléspectateurs et si c'est quand même
pas mal un peu d'accord avec les
isabelle et géraldine quand ils disent à
par marleau problème ils sont loin
derrière tf1 ils ont bien d'autres trucs
qui marque d'accord sur divertissement
avec sa soeur et n'ont rien on est
d'accord ordinaires à hauteur du rendez
vous sur une grille
j'ai dû laisser partir patrick sébastien
ça ça a été la seule économie sont pas
un gars c'est clair pourquoi il peut
être pas christophe dechavanne bah oui
mais bon divertissement
alors oui christophe et d'autres tel
point qu'il est ils excellent ah non la
sib à 6,6 et isolée par des meilleurs
ils ont cueilli si l'on va peut-être
lancer ma vie et ses nouveaux animateurs
et des nouvelles sinon mais ça ne
postule en silence dans le mur 0e
chercher avec qui ils vont chercher que
cyril féraud il faut il ya ces référents
qui cartonne sur fois mais cyril c'est
le bon mais il est sur fond noir
ils vont pas le mettre aussi sur france
2 le pauvre cyril féraud aidera
construit leur habité il a envie de
souffler un peu le mettre dans toutes
les émissions le nom mais en plus il
faudrait le mettre plus on prend une
scierie terme c'est le meilleur c'est
vrai yanagi cyril féraud après le reste
frère excuse-moi michel drucker
heureusement killer après il faut savoir
c'est que tous les animateurs plus ou
moins qui sont aujourd'hui même sur tf1
ils viennent du service public jean
pierre foucault et du service public
viennent tous du service public m'avait
problème pourquoi y at il des raisons
financières aussi parce que la loi
entraînerait les animateurs aime
l'argent à des moyens de production et
on en parlera tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
du grand échiquier fois qu'on en pense
qu'ils sont nous n'avons pas parlé ce
soir mais si tu veux appelle des fois
t'es pas là
non mais non mais je te mets c'est vrai
pourquoi ils n'ont pas un animateur à
france 2 de divertissement et pourquoi
ils n'ont pas un gros format je demande
à chaque fois c'est quoi leur grosse
cartouche à ce qu'aujourd'hui il avait
tombé d'accord mais regardez sur une
grillade art et puis disons il ya de
vraies formations illusion d d'accord
mais dur a dit est-ce que jamais après
je voudrais isabelle comme argent télé
parce que je voudrais savoir en tant que
néophyte quoi capitaine marc locon ça
passe sur france 3 sarapp même si ça
fait un million de plus est ce que ça
rapporte moins d'argent donc que france
2 alors on fait un million de moi vous
expliquer quelque chose de ma chérie il
n'y a pas de pub appalaches de 20h sur
france télé avant ils n'arrivent pas à
financer quand même avant d'en cas pas
comme ça t'inquiète pas non franchement
ça changera un peu après pour moi je le
dis nicolas pernikoff je pense que c'est
une connerie de la morbide vendredi moi
parce que le mardi yves moi moi je vais
vous dire mais j'ai milité pour qu'ils
aillent le vendredi parce qu au moins ça
nous fait un truc que en moins fort le
mardi bon alors je très bien mais en
vrai le vendredi ils savaient leur
fiction qui marchait très bien
ils ont candice peau noire qui marche
très bien ils ont leur agatha christie
qui marche très bien sûr mais ils ont
plein de trucs qui marchent très bien
qui fait 4 4,5 millions pourquoi aller
chercher un truc qui fait 6 à 7 millions
alors que ça a cartonné mardi bien sûr
c'est une énorme erreur pour moi voilà à
prix font ce qu'ils veulent mais pour
nous les autres chaînes on égale voilà
on se régale on est très content parce
que au moins on sait que le vendredi
elle est le vendredi si tout le monde
met toutes ses forces au vendredi et que
le reste mardi on sait que sur tf1 y à
rien parce qu'il ya soit tous voila mais
c'est de la merde voilà non mais c'est
vrai le mardi sur france 2 il met un
divertissement que même ma mère elle
sait même pas ce que c'est non mais sans
rigoler le françois donc bah y'a jamais
rien voilà si voix la france 3 on sait
que ça marche à chaque fois mais bon
c'est pour les les voilà les personnes
tiken qui en france trois mois je n'ai
pas sainement je n'ai pas et tu as m6
qui se mue en avec leurs conneries sur
ménagères voilà maintenant c'est pour ça
qu'elle ci se régale le mardi soir
sérieusement dans la main oui parce que
france télévisions aujourd'hui sur un an
alors c'est leur stratégie une
harmonisation de genre ouais alors
qu'avant il y avait des grands rendez
vous sur les chaînes aujourd'hui moi je
pense qu'on a besoin de rendez vous sur
les chaînes ou loyers bien m6 s'est
construite cette manière là on sait ce
qu'on va repartir de ne pas à toi france
télé parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pu l'âge
de retourner à thémines
des conneries mais vous rigolez ou quoi
c'est un job ou nantes à dire qu'ils
sont fous rien je dis juste que diriger
une unité de programmes dans une chaîne
de télévision c'est un boulot full time
l'avait très bien vous parlez aux
animateurs le samedi le dimanche passé
votre vie à faire ça vous avez plus de
vie de famille c'est vrai quand vous
l'avez fait pendant cinq ou six ans je
pense que ça a été
vous êtes là d'où des animateurs en fait
comme en êtes la nounou des années oui
bien sûr elle est obligée de les
rassurer quand ça marche pas vous êtes
obligé de parler à patrick sébastien le
dimanche matin
drucker alors ça ne me dit tu es
plaisait pas à l'époque mais je trouve
ça dur et prenons si vous faites bien le
job c'est intéressant ce qu'il dira
c'est intéressant si oui il avait en
tout cas vous avez raison le capitaine
marc loos a eut atteint quasiment 9
millions mais marc bien sûr à la région
mauvais ils les feront pas sur l'aide
venant de toute façon et quant à quentin
qu'en dix ans en conclusion elle est
adorable moi je n'entends pas en groupe
aimer mais en revanche elle a commis une
erreur dans des régions ne sont pas
payées on est passé au curé commis une
erreur mais voulue appel mais trop news
qu'elle anime ses collègues elle
connaissait pas koh lanta cctv regarder
koh lanta l'aurais jamais fait cette
erreur stratégique de ce qu'offre la
haye tronyo le chocolat et les tue